foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what up everybody welcome to the show uh
we're here guys we are here how y'all
feeling today man how y'all feeling
I got no complaints man
Christmas was good got a new pair of
kicks everybody's healthy everybody's
happy just gotta win some bets that's
all that's left Ryan did you get what
you wanted for Christmas I just need to
know did you get what you wanted or
how's that going uh well I wanted Jordan
Poole to make three plus threes last
week as like an early Christmas present
and I didn't get that so uh kind of
ruined my holiday season I won't lie
well Ryan I mean just being on both of
our shows you you're known as the I told
you show guy but I just want to let you
and MB know throughout that show last
week I told y'all about Jordan pool in
those threes I I told y'all but that's
okay that is okay because today
we're gonna get right I'm feeling good
we're gonna get right uh I've created
from everybody yeah hold on Greg I've
branded myself as not and I Told You So
guy I don't know I'm not and I Told You
So guy I don't know if that's accurate
right whether it's accurate or not
that's what I brand myself as
I love it I love it we have to I don't
know we have to we have to ask the
audience if they brand you as that Ryan
because
they're the ones that make the decisions
like you know you might think that
that's what you're branded as so if you
come on this show and you constantly say
I told you so I told you so so you know
I I do want anything well speaking of
the audience I do want to shout out B
Thompson who jumped in here before the
show started and said just want to say I
was right about my nuggets and jokic uh
Joe jokic here we go again I know dude
the Joker that he was gonna have eight
assists so B Thompson I told you some
guy he's the I Told You So guy shout out
to him though he was right all right
today's version of I Told You So guy B
Thompson shout out to you thank you for
being a loyal fan to the show but let me
introduce everyone my name is Greg Ivory
next to me is the man I call MB you
might know him as Michael Bolin and next
to him is the man we like to call around
here producer Ryan last week we built
our five leg parlays so today
we're running it back but we got to see
one go through the basket make sure you
guys drop your best bet for tonight in
the chat and we'll cook them into a
parlay Ryan talk to us
we gave the chat an ample amount of time
to fill in some comments what are they
talking about well I just want to toss
out here quickly because we're usually
only TNT games there is no TNT games
tonight so the board is ours we have
much at our disposal look at this I mean
look at this guys look at this we have
games through if you're on the East
Coast we have games through the 10
o'clock hour look at this I could keep
scrolling
so whatever you guys want
uh B Thompson very big on on jokic uh
tonight just to just to get ahead of
that
um but as he should be as he should be
on Christmas day that man went
absolutely insane yeah will he keep it
up also
maybe not the maybe not the show to talk
about it but sneaky three MVPs in a row
ah kind of hearing it
I can see it
I could see it
so the way he's playing I mean the way
he's playing I can definitely see it
it'd be
you put up 40 points in 27 rebounds I
mean
you do that I mean has
got me you only need to do that a
handful of times you get people on
notice yeah
Ryan do you see anything that that
catches your attention though we got to
lock in one leg is there anything that
catches your attention or did you think
of anything before the show you know
what we're looking for here Ryan we're
only looking for Scoops yes well Greg I
always think of things before the show
but you put me on blast when the show
starts so I decided not to share with
you uh I think I think today may be the
day that we that we choose a side in a
game I think that that's that's where I
land uh Bull Run says remember this is a
parlay so we don't need to go crazy with
the whole like we taking an underdog
money line uh we could take some Shock
if we want but Bull Run said Wizards
money line
um let's see we've got Dante cash cash
on says Spencer Dinwiddie 15 plus points
uh I see a take from JD uh 804 about
Austin Reeves and I saw the word over
Austin Reeves awesome yeah oh Panda band
uh Wayne 60 jokic uh over nine assists
so
Mo Productions Lakers plus four I don't
know how you guys feel about betting on
the Lakers but that's uh
this feels like a trendy pick
um I've seen it on Twitter a little bit
I can't believe they're not favored or
it's closer that the only thing that I
would say is
they should win that game but no idea
Brian is random
I see a scoop
I see a scoop how did I miss that Pablo
bonchero oh yeah
yeah 20 plus points well not a scoop
it's a play there's a difference Greg oh
that's a scoop brother all right well
let's say yeah
I mean you're right but like
a scoop can be a play and nothing can be
a school
says he wants to show off in front of
LeBron so he likes Paolo bancaro so
maybe that is a scoop see
that's enough for me I like see I'm cool
with this
I like MB and B knows how to you know
make make it flow he makes it flow
and just just to add to it I think for
sure Paula bonquero is a rookie of the
year he's had a hell of a season I think
the magic are
really fun team I think they're probably
one player away from like actually
making the playoffs and being a team
that like makes some noise so if we want
to lock in Paolo I'm all over it at 150
I like 55 that's not a bad play at all
yeah I'm in there it is there it is we
got one leg down we're feeling good
we're here we are feeling good uh Ryan I
I know you are a man of the people you
are a man of the people but I'm in the
car interesting choice of words there
I've read the comments right now and I
see Tyrese Halliburton 35 points
rebounds and assist 35 Plus points
rebound is and assist that was given to
us by the real
kr215 and that one caught my attention
guys like we don't have to ride with it
but you know this is the people's parlay
and that one caught my attention
do you guys like it do you guys want to
consider it do we even want to talk
about it I need input well I kind of
want to talk about it because I'm sure
as everybody knows last week Wally
zerbiak called Tyrese Halliburton out
and said he was a wannabe All-Star and
all he's done after that is absolutely
cook that man has had he had 10 threes
in a game not too long ago over 40
points he's one of the better players
that the Pacers got he's probably the
best player on the team to be honest and
I don't know I think he's very much in
the Limelight right now and I think he's
got something to prove after he's been
getting chirped at so I don't know if
the pra is the is the move for the
parlay but definitely something we
should talk about I think
I'm with it I'll I'm gonna look at his
rebound and assist numbers in the past
few games
um but I agree on the something to prove
also uh some really high level analysis
here the Hawks stink uh they're not good
so I'm I'm cool with this just because I
I think the Hawks are not good and he's
the Pacers best player so okay Ryan you
want to give us some recent games on
this uh p r a uh I would love to Greg I
would love to so yeah of course uh so
last game not a good one uh 12 points
one rebound six assists uh but before
that before that uh 43 points I don't
even think I need to read the other ones
but I will anyway uh two rebounds seven
assists uh game before that 33 points uh
three rebounds eight assists
like I said he was playing the he was
playing the Pelicans on the 20 or he was
playing the pal why does it say
s oh
Ryan just had a malfunction
it says December 27th is today not
December 27th it is today is the 27th
okay well the app I'm using needs to
figure it out
all right so we get the point though we
get the point yeah yeah I meant he's
been balling he's been balling MB also
came with the scoop and said uh you know
he got called out in the media he got
caught out in the media we'll just leave
it at that because I don't agree with
that my man has been balling uh so
let's ask the audience let's ask the
audience guys do we want to lock in
Tyrese Halliburton over is that 33 and a
half Ryan
uh it is 3 33 and a half 33 and a half
over 33 and a half points rebounds and
assists we need thumbs up in the
comments if you guys like it thumbs down
in the comments if you guys do not like
it just a little just a little feedback
from the chat uh Wayne 60 said Tyrese
was garbage last night we went over that
obviously but flip dollar confirming
they're in the second game of a back to
back so maybe that makes us hesitate a
little bit
I think that's a good way to handicap
some of these games but
you'll see what the chat things
yeah that was going to be my take on
some of these but my man my man right
Michael Ritter says you like how I says
his name I hope I'm saying it right I
think I am saying it right and it can't
be worse than the way I say jokic
all right here we go we're getting some
feedback in the comments I stopped and
uh I see a lot of thumbs down all right
yeah I do too we can move on yeah we can
we got an entire slate we got all night
I don't know how long it's going to take
for them to kick us off this show but
you know we've had some we've had some
weeks where they've you know kind of got
to get out at a certain time like I feel
like we can stretch our legs today so
bring bring the locks in here bring the
locks we got the chef's hat on we're
gonna cook uh I did see before the
Halliburton play uh aloe jumped in and
said Houston Rockets plus 15 against the
Boston Celtics
the Rockets are on a back to back
Houston Rockets
Houston Rockets just beat the hell out
of the Bulls last night so I'm
officially back out on my Chicago Bulls
after a few good games by them I thought
the Rockets looked the Rockets looked
good last night the Rockets might be
good like they traveled from Chicago to
Boston 15 points is a ton of points man
so many that's a ton of points guys but
jokic I
like the comments the comments is
talking about it yogic he's been bawling
why let's let's talk about that I feel
like the points rebounds and assists
should be easy money
well I did see rebounds and assists at
20 plus with jokic oh we'll come back to
our to our beautiful Houston Rockets uh
in a little bit but we'll we'll go to
we'll go to jokic yeah we're not we're
not leaving our Rockets alone we'll be
back
we have to we need context there Ryan
because because Vegas has given us 15
points for a reason and it's the Rockets
facing your Celtics yeah we need some
context from you so so we'll we'll put a
pin in it all right yeah yeah we'll put
a pit in it but all right I I saw 20
from B Thompson I saw uh over 20 and a
half I think it was rebounds and assists
for jokic oh it's at 21 and a half
how do we feel about that
I like it I don't know if we need to
lock in on the rebounds and assists only
I think the pra is interesting also I
think
just the boards I mean like he's been
it's a lot he's been getting like 15
boards a game at least for the last week
I feel like so there's a lot of plays in
here with yoker and I'm double checking
right now but I think sabonis might be
hurt like who's gonna guard him on the
Kings bro might as well lock in the pra
even though it's a lot my man's been
falling and like MB said who's gonna
guard him on the king seriously like
let's really think about it I'll look up
the king's roster and we can literally
go down the roster and see who's gonna
guard
did you guys see the pra it's at 48 and
a half that doesn't what okay so go go
look at what he's done and then let's
compare like we do everybody else we do
it to everybody else why change it yeah
but it's if it's Tyrese whatever fine
fine I'll do it we do it to everybody
Ryan why are we changing he doesn't get
he doesn't get the everybody treatment
Greg he doesn't get the everybody
treatment
that's I'm confused on what treatment
should he get when we got scored 41
points last game he scored 41 points
last game exactly okay so why are we
scared of a 45 and a half
rebounds and assists because on December
21st he scored 13 against Memphis and
I'm afraid that's what's gonna happen
here here
Memphis has somebody that can actually
go guard him I mean Steven Adams he's a
big guy all right
Jerry Jackson's victims advocate
Devil's Advocate is
they might blow out the Kings tonight
and he may only play three quarters that
would be my only argument against but
I'm kind of leaning with Greg
dude he's been way over this number so
many times and dude's an animal if we're
gonna trust anyone to get over that
number it's him
blowout who who's going to blow out who
nuggets might blow out the Kings yeah I
mean Sacramento
he's out tonight
yeah I I I hear UMB the Kings play well
in Sacramento I'll just say that they
like to like the beam in Sacramento so
why did you know sabonis sabonis the
Kings play well there
brother you're talking about Sacramento
like it's the garden like this they'd be
lucky if 15 of their
attendance hit like what are we doing
here no no whoa whoa whoa they've been
selling out bro do you not know the kids
because the arena has 20 seats if the
playoffs were in if the playoffs were to
end I mean if the playoffs were tomorrow
the Kings would be in
I don't know I just want you to know
that
interesting get to Sacramento this much
love
right I mean I'm just saying
I think it's more of a joker discussion
and less of a king's discussion I worry
about the blowout but he's one of my
favorite players so if we want to lock
it in I'm in worry about worried about
the blowout do we just take nuggets
money line remember this is a parlay we
don't have to keep doing it
okay that's a good lean Ryan I don't
disagree with the Nuggets money line but
what's the spread can we go up
oh foreign
they don't have to win they're not
they're nine and six at home that's
decent you know yeah it's decent yeah
it's above average they lit the beam
nine times
all right we gotta get a pet game I kind
of like the nuggets
what's the line let me see minus four I
don't man guys this looks trappy to me
but but go ahead it yeah as long as I'm
on record saying that this looks trappy
in yokich p r a it's I can't do this
with you
we can we can we can lock it if we want
to do the pra the pra was dropped if we
wanted to do the pra so badly I'm in but
we got to start adjusting some of these
lines because I don't need to take a
minus 120 every single one of these for
five like parlay I hear you I I totally
hear you bro we'll take the pra that's
what the chat dropped I I won't try and
also I see zibia in here Sacramento fans
get Ryan there's not enough Sacramento
fans to come get which is not enough
hey yo Sacramento will come after you
bro they those fans are loyal they've
been losing for I don't know how long
and they still show up to games and sell
out that Arena they are loyal it's
something in the water in Sacramento no
but they're loyal to those kings fans
correct to those kings you better be
careful I think the I think the opposing
team's fans are the ones selling out
that Arena I don't think it's the case
all right Ryan I got some contacts up
there I can get you to come along for a
tour
here we go now we're talking
all right let me tap back into the chat
because I got a really interesting one
from Philip Marquez Luke Canard over two
threes his last five games from three
four of eight to a four four eight four
six four of seven and I've been cooking
on these shout out to you for giving us
a the play and the handicap in the
comment that's A1 stuff
okay
I like that MB
am I was I missing something or did I
not see Luke Canard
and is he not on there oh that would be
sad he's not there because that would be
beautiful
so he's got to be there
Hey Soul maybe they won't allow him to
do two threes maybe you have to get two
solid legs he's not even here for the
regular
that's bizarre unless he got traded from
the Clippers and overnight and he's on a
different team but that's you know see
if a riot they they know they know hey
Ryan you can you know how to multitask
the comments wants to know dude if you
hate Philly or sack more but oh more
also Sam Richmond jumped in here Ryan's
never been to California and it shows
I've been to San Francisco let's relax
okay I've been in California before
uh
Sacramento or Philly no it's Philly come
on come on it's not even close I've
never been to Sacramento and more to the
point there's no reason to go to
Sacramento and that's what I like them
bro you're being so disrespectful right
now that is the capital of California
that is
not a great city of Sacramento I'm
not it's the Connecticut of the West
Coast nobody goes there if you're in
California you're driving right by
Sacramento to get to either Los Angeles
or San Francisco maybe even San Diego
well that's how I know you don't know
geography because you don't drive
through Sacramento to get to either of
those places
you have to cook this parlay and stop
talking about Sacramento please God uh
Mike Steve Ritter uh rise never see
ladybird and it shows I have seen Lady
Bird so let's stop with the slander I've
been to California and I've seen
ladybird
all right all right let's lock into play
we need to play all right we we we're at
plus 201 Ryan I think it's time to start
the alternate spread thing you know how
we do yeah you know what I'm talking
about we go back to the Rockets yes
love it love that I absolutely love that
let's go there's no way
let's lock it in let's lock it in I like
that plus 25 that has me feeling real
confident
against your Boston Celtics too yeah oh
look at this minus 410 that's great
value Great Value lock that one in we're
three legs in
bowling your your faces
I I'm honestly like I'm laying out so
you guys could just have your time
because this is like the funniest thing
I've ever seen we're talking about the
state capital of California for 20
minutes and then we put a minus 410 play
in here that's like
[Laughter]
uh Matt Uncle Mal jumps in here that pra
is a trap I mean we we talked about this
10 minutes ago
Sacramento too much this is too much
[Music]
Mal's also jumping in talking about
Horford over three points like over
three let's take a look let's take a
look let's take a look I'm down I'm down
he's been Ryan does he even hit threes
no he does he was smacking him on
Christmas Greg yeah
as somebody who took court for 10 plus
points uh he was on fire so yes sir this
is a good play Uncle Mal has this he's
got he's got the Sharp plays and I
watched that game that was a pretty good
game obviously Tatum went off but
orford's always hanging out in that
corner making threes man yeah he's
pretty reliable can I ask Uncle Mal
do you are you talking about over two
and a half because that's very juicy or
are you talking like two plus because
again this is a parlay and we can let's
go to the plus I think two plus yeah two
plus yeah two plus would be minus two
ten that puts us in a good spot
yeah I like two plus
I like it right two plus
if we do if we were to do
uh Uncle Mouse said he said it 10
minutes ago again yeah sorry I was
slandering Sacramento that's my bad
that puts us at a good spot to add
something like somewhat safe as this
fifth leg and my goal is to get this to
plus 600 so I don't know how you guys
feel but I I feel pretty good about this
the spot that works yes sir
Kawhi Leonard over points 20 points oh
six four saying 20 points
oh okay I mean again are we concerned
with the Clippers on a back to back
uh I think you always have to be
especially with anything with Kawhi
Leonard and the back to back you are
heavily concerned and I will say this
they almost lost they almost lost last
night because I bet Clippers money line
in a parlay and who do they play I'm
trying to remember they oh they played
the Pistons they played the Pistons uh
they were down 14 late put in their
scrub Squad and the scrub Squad came all
the way back and they won in overtime
they played an overtime game yesterday I
this is my me advocating for Raptors
money line
oh somebody put that in the chat earlier
did they
somebody had it in here I'm gonna go
back and look uh somebody was like
second game of back to back Clippers on
the road in Toronto could you imagine oh
looks like he didn't play last night all
right oh so we're definitely dude that's
a narrative too he's going back to
Toronto yeah yeah you're right let's go
that's a good Scoop flip dollar really
that is a good Scoop MB flip dollar is
six of six from the field in the chat
tonight and I love it yes just throwing
in some good Heat
that is a great scoop MB
I'm gonna double check flip dollar and
make sure he didn't play last night
um but yeah double check that if he
didn't play last night and he's coming
back oh we're riding with Kawaii
either righty
absolutely
it's night I don't know why this gives
me
Ryan no we no no you've done this plenty
of times and we've no yeah we're riding
we are rocking with Kawaii we got a
scoop he didn't play last night he's
going back to Toronto he's gonna ball
we're riding
yes we're riding Ryan you gotta you
gotta fill it with this bro you just
just just fake it fake it I'm not a fake
until you make it guy but I will say
this this line is very Juiced up uh so
there's that because I feel like
everyone in America and our our brothers
and sisters up in Canada is probably
betting on this uh over
do we want to tease it down to 15 plus
let's see why not let's see what it
let's see what it says yeah let's take a
look
[Music]
I kind of like it I don't hate it I like
to have I think we have to have a
discussion low-key about the Joker leg
though I think I'm seeing a lot of chat
saying that's gonna be the leg that
smokes us no
I'm telling you
[Laughter]
um I love it I love when I love when
Greg's like I'm telling you because
normally when he says that it does hit
but we always kind of like go off of it
like the Greg leg and we got the Greg
leg in and it did so I'm feeling the
vibe if you say it's good it's good I'm
telling you let's let that man cook
let's watch let's Rejoice let's let's
celebrate tonight because I really like
this parlay guys I really really like
this parlay there's not too many times
B Thompson says thumbs up Mal says he
likes it zippy326 thumbs up
B Thompson says Let It Ride I think we
might have it Uncle Mal Joker pra trap
yeah
we gotta give love to the negative
comments guys we can't just cherry pick
as somebody who Cherry picks every week
the comments that he reads we have we
have to give love to some of these
negative comments
it's okay okay my guy Logan Bagel
unlocked saying can we do LeBron 25 plus
instead
he's had 30 and seven straight games
that means nothing to me
yeah absolutely nothing no but they are
playing the magic though like
he's gonna cook bro
oh my gosh you guys
okay why don't we just add it as a leg
it's not just like
let's go let's go
I'm down bro I don't even care man this
is hilarious if we have a six-legger
with LeBron which we know is gonna hit
we're still gonna Sweat The Joker prop
anyway but we're gonna get a bunch of
money I think we're gonna I really don't
know why we're sweating about the jokic
like that's gonna be the easiest lock of
the night
so much this is amazing
can we tease something down with jokic
okay
no no no no if we if we add Brawn we
could tease something down with your
kids I'll be down with that yeah
here we go this is where I like to cook
all right so how so how do we tease down
the points rebounds and assist I don't
know how you can do that do they allow
you oh I was gonna offer something of
different jokes related but yeah because
I don't think we can
I don't know how we feel about that but
I mean if we were confident in points
rebounds and assists we were pretty much
confident in every
everything absolutely yeah absolutely I
love I love the way you're thinking Ryan
I love let's continue the talk let's
continue the dialogue today man I'm on
one because we might we might be we
might be going in that right direction
we might be going in the right direction
so so continue please
I told uh I told bowling this before the
show I dealt with Three Times Square
Buzz Light Years today and through all
this adversity I'm still standing giving
place a phoenix Rose from the ocean yeah
that's what I like
uh
I don't know do we like it I like his
assist is always like treated us well I
feel like eight assists is probably
where we can net out and feel
comfortable yep yep I like that it
doesn't do what I wanted it to do
we can mess around we could Tinker this
and tease down the Rockets a little bit
maybe to like 22.
okay a lot of people think the Rockets
might actually win tonight so I'm down
to tease them down that's not I mean
we're talking about a huge blowout if
they lose by 23 we still cash I'm down
all right yeah I would like to see what
Uncle Mal thinks of
I mean he's talking about lamello
three-pointers yeah he's talking about
mellow three-pointers I I hear you Uncle
Mao but
is Uncle Mal locky why are we singling
out uncle uncle okay he's like he's one
of our community captains and he's
definitely lucky he has he has the plays
I don't know I I'm definitely more on
board with the The Joker play than maybe
a lot of people I guess that's just me
and you Greg against the world but if he
says look at lamelo threes we should
take a peek
as a man of the people the man of the
people
if I don't know you then like you know
um
your law credibility might be
in the air so
Uncle mile you gotta tap in bro that's
all I'm saying you gotta tap in so I
gotta know if you're really lucky or not
because this whole show our whole parlay
is riding on you that's what it seems
like it's it's riding on you
and what you're trying to do so tap in
bro please step in uh Ryan how we
looking on the parlay though six legs is
the only plus set what the six legs
yeah it's just stressing me out because
if I go to if we go to lamelo threes is
that three and a half we already have
six legs uh a seventh leg uh for me
personally is off the table here off the
top absolutely absolutely I I would
argue that maybe we need to take away a
leg already but me too me too Ryan I'm
I'm in the same boat six legs for for
plus 474 is not enough dude it's not
doing it
[Music]
thing but like what are we taking out
so like just a review for everybody
we've got Houston Rockets plus 25 and a
half lock hour for two plus made threes
maybe Paulo bencharo 20 plus points
LeBron James 25 plus that's the that's
the Logan leg
um
and then we've got Kawhi 15 plus points
and jokic eight plus assists
it's kind of unlucky
I don't know because you know the
environment in Sacramento is so rowdy I
don't know if yokich is going to be able
to to get his assists up to eight why
don't we just throw I mean I don't know
I don't hate the idea of just tossing in
the the lamella threes I don't care man
literally 30 seconds 30 seconds ago I go
seven legs is off the table and bowling
agreed and now we're at a point where we
have a plus 907 leg parlay but that's
fun though that's what the people want
the people want okay so then we need to
says Perkins is saying y'all are playing
it too safe take Kawhi 20 points and
Denver money line are we being too safe
no I think we're being Reckless I think
we're being Reckless it's all hell right
now we need to I think we this is what
we need to do if we're going to do this
we need to tease down
the living hell out of everything else
that we've we've put in here like I want
oh no I think what I was saying was
instead of doing 15 points for Kawhi
let's do 20.
no I no no I I know what you were saying
I'm saying I don't I would rather go I
would rather go Greg do you get what I'm
saying
I would rather y'all love me I I would
rather us if we're gonna lean on Uncle
Mal here and go lamelo over three and a
half threes which is a lot by the way
then I would like the other legs to make
me sweat less so rather than try and
Juice this baby all the way up let's
just knock it down a few pegs oh so what
you're saying is take LeBron 20 points
instead of 25. ah looking at everything
else
yeah you could also probably talk me
into jokic6 plus assist but uh yes he's
gonna get eight assists
yeah let's see what let's see what the
LeBron stuff does here all right let's
get rid of you and
flip Dallas said seven is God and he got
us so Anthony Anthony Marciano says
Joker pra was the money exactly I don't
yeah we're done yeah this is push seven
legs in yeah this is reckless right you
don't even in your heart you don't even
do things like this what are we what are
you doing right now I don't I know I'm
I'm a four like parlay guy and we're
what are you doing you're setting legs
in at plus 700
okay
mellow three plus you can't jump in here
and say take the over threes and then
want to tease it down
he might have said over three plus
so this is Uncle Mouse parlay let's just
call it Uncle miles parlay we might as
well brand it that way no because this
guy has so much so much so much pool on
our parlay
I think I think we're all missing the
point I don't even know if it was his
original play he was just trying to put
push it to the Forefront because he
thinks it's alive I don't know
got to this big is far late but if we
get just three threes in there what does
it do because I'm ready to go drink a
beer this is a stressful show no I need
something stronger than beer after this
okay we're at seven legs at plus 531.
why are we putting in lamelo ball to
make three threes at minus 390. that
makes no sense to me when we can go get
jokish pra at minus what 110 minus 120.
the broken shot lamelo
even though he's been shooting it better
but we want to put our faith in lamelo
just go back and put the Joker pra in
and let's just go with our gut that's
what we have to do thank you that's what
that's what we have to do and this is
what I want to do for our social media
people who clip this show out clip that
little rant together from Greg and then
we're branding this as the Greg leg I
want this as I want the Greg leg next to
it and whatever graphic that we put
look at hey and then Mal says I want
your pra in there what this guy's all
over the place and we're believing in
him we're believing he's all over the
place this is the most this is the most
interactive we've got some milk
y go get him the milk
where's the milk carton at
least give us our
pra and let's get out of here
this is I think I I took out LeBron that
this is
now he's talking about Uncle Mal
approved
oh man are you crazy bro
yeah LeBron LeBron is out this is our
new six like parlay
Houston Rockets plus 25 and a half
Al Horford two plus made threes
Paolo bencaro 20 plus points
where are we Kawhi Leonard 15 plus
points lamelo ball three plus made
threes no take that out take lamelo out
please Ryan I would much rather have
LeBron than lamelo no material the
LeBron leg was minus five thousand and
then jokic over 48 and a half points
rebounds yes minus 5 000 for a reason
Ryan I would much rather take
wait wait wait wait wait
we teased LeBron down to 20 because we
had the other stuff in we originally
wanted 25. so if we're gonna have LeBron
and just go back to 25. are we taking
lamelo out yes yes
please take lamello out okay Zay said
keep the LeBron take Horford out
okay we could talk about that time
because I I because I don't really like
Horford threes either
okay what what do you like this 25
points Horford's out ball is out press
the button I don't think but no I don't
think we would take a ball out I don't
think I don't think that's what we were
doing no that's what we need to do take
both brother
there's gonna be no juice left in this
he's minus 390 bro what juice is that
take him out and put LeBron back in plus
25 and we're good we're good oh my
goodness gracious all right so what am I
I'm taking out lamello watch what this
does man watch what this does it doesn't
matter
I think we're back to where we started
that's the point we where we started
with the good we I don't even know why
we left
are we okay with this
read it out again I thought it was more
juicier than that that's what I'm saying
Greg why are we we're replacing stuff
that's we go we'll go back and forth
back and forth the entire time I'm
saying look at what we're doing to the
odds and nobody's listening
but what happened I feel like Ryan I
feel like Ryan's gonna go on a like a
WFAN style
I mean my good the Buzz light years are
finally getting to me man Paulo Ben Caro
20 plus points LeBron James 25 plus
points Rockets plus 25 and a half Kawhi
Leonard 15 plus points that's what we
did
yeah well you need to I can't I can't
take 20 plus with Kawaii the Rockets was
the move though to move it down to like
22. wait wait also also I'm being told
and I know this that we took Al Horford
out and that's why we lost the juice I'm
just saying Al Horford doesn't seem like
a popular play so we need to figure
something mellow doesn't either but but
but
[Laughter]
Kawhi Leonard's gonna ball bro why are
we going only 15 points with Kauai bring
that up to 20. boom
bring that up to 20 man
put that to 20 and let's send it you
know and watch what it do right put that
up to 20 and then watch what it do you
minus 125. it gets it yeah I mean I no I
don't like it I love it but it's like
[Laughter]
I don't like it I love it that's what
that thing in and let's ride there it is
right look that's what you like that's
your type of vibe that's your type of
parlay that is your that's all you bro
don't not don't do this don't say that
it's all me because then when this loses
that's yeah right exactly it's all me
and then when this loses I'm gonna have
to face the music don't do this
let's get out of here bro for too long
yeah
Paulo Ben Caro 20 plus points LeBron
James 25 plus points Houston Rockets
plus 25 and a half Nikolai jokic over 48
and a half points rebounds assists and
then Kawhi Leonard 20 plus points it's a
five leg parlay
that adds up to plus 734. I just want
you to know that I do too the the chat
is absolutely hysterical all these games
and y'all can't put together a five
teamer come on get it together y'all are
lost they're supposed to be helping us
this is so good I can't wait to bet this
for my with my 20 Free Bet okay we need
to get Uncle Mal hey what pick did Uncle
Mal give us what pick did he give us uh
he gave us did we take it we took them
both out
all right Uncle mount
put your picks in the chat if you hit
send him to a game we gotta send him to
a ride along or something we have to we
have to send him to a game send him to a
ride along incorporate we want to send
you guys you guys that come to this to
this show every week we want to give
back to you guys so uh Uncle Mal you're
gonna be our first one put your locks in
the chat and if you hit man we're gonna
highly consider bringing you to the next
Rider one
gonna have also in the app right now if
you have won
in the whole calendar year your best
wins from the NBA season tap in with us
and drop them in community we're giving
out merch
there it is there it is Ryan give it to
him one more time and then we about to
get a buddy here MB trying to drink a
beer I'm trying to go win some bets uh
one more time yeah I'm the only one who
didn't who didn't give something away in
that in that speech that whole little
that whole little Spiel I don't have
anything to give away I guess if you're
from Sacramento don't don't end up in my
DMs tonight
um Apollo Peg Caro 20 plus points LeBron
James 25 plus points
the Houston Rockets plus 25 and a half
against the Boston Celtics Nikolai jokic
over 48 and a half points rebounds and
assists and the Nuggets blow out of the
Kings tonight and then Kawhi letter 20
plus points in his return to the six
and two of those picks were flipped
dollar 23. so
don't catch me calling it The Flip
dollar parlay because oh oh oh oh oh if
it doesn't hit if it doesn't hit there's
a lot of pressure to it though I got a
ring to it it does flip dollar we about
to flip something yeah fail me Hey
That's it man we about it here my name
is Greg next to me is MB I call him MB
all might call them Michael Bola and
next to him is the guy we like to call
the mister I Told You So guys producer
Ryan
I thought man of the people that I
thought that was gonna happen
One of These Days Grace hey amen amen
hey we about it here though y'all we up
out of here let's go with some money
peace
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]